what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch from new rock stars their easter
eggs and break down for what if episode
three if you didn't catch our reaction
that is now up on the youtubes eric voss
very very kind gentlemen as predicted in
our opening sketch i was just calling to
let you know that
even if our reaction video goes up later
than yours
we'll still get more views
why are you guys getting into reactions
now too don't you already have the most
viewed breakdowns and now will be the
most watched reaction channel too
[Laughter]
and i don't even need to put my face in
the thumbnail
son of a bee surpassed us
no face in the thumbnail and got his up
after ours
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 3 in which the avengers
get a taste of another kind of vengeance
that ends up popping the hulk like a zit
boom you looking for this
i'm gonna go back through this episode
frame by frame for all the easter eggs
and hidden animation details that you
might have overlooked we open on monday
this episode uses days of the week to
structure its five acts because this is
what's known in the marvel timeline as
fury's big week in which the events of
iron man 2 hulk and thor all take place
at the same time based off of some
newsreel footage that we saw at the end
of iron man 2 in a line in iron man 2
about coulson headed off to new mexico
why don't they call this
what if
nick fury
had a nope it's the right title
what if nick fury's big week went really
poorly what if it was nick fury's bad
week bad week that's the nick fury's no
good very terrible absolutely they
pigeonholed themselves because they have
to have the word what if at the
beginning of each title episode it's
their fault it's their fault they had a
miss opportunity fury drives with
natasha romanov there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people to see if they could become
something more i know i've heard this
page samuel l jackson is back as fury
natasha is actually voiced by lake bell
this is of course his fury's big speech
that he uses to rally cap and tony after
coulson's death in the 2012 avengers
film there was an idea to bring together
a group of remarkable people see if they
could become something more see if they
could work together when we needed them
to to fight the battles that we never
could what i love about this is that in
the mud f show he says i wrote the
script or something i wrote the speech
so i love that he had that speech
prepared written out in advance to use
the right moment to inspire and motivate
people good preparation because i
thought it played out like he's
improvising this from the heart but
apparently nick fury had it planned all
along natasha's pointed finger lines up
perfectly with the reflection of tony
sitting in the donut this shop is
randy's donuts in los angeles but the
framing of most of the shots here kind
of frames out the randy's including the
windows and the interior shots
marvel can see the ra at the top of the
donut there all the framing and music
and dialogue here is mirrored from iron
man 2. sir
i'm gonna have to ask you to exit the
donut though in the movie on the
sidewalk was 3 16 for john 3 16. for god
so loved the world that he gave his one
and only son that whoever believes in
him shall not perish but have eternal
life which as a detail in iron man 2 i
always liked as a reflection of that
movie's father and son themes with
howard stark offering his only son tony
as this sacrificial savior of humanity
but 316 does not appear here maybe as a
way of showing that in this universe
tony stark never gets the chance to be
that savior as he does in the movie tony
says i told you good attention
now tony is voiced here not by robert
downey jr but by mick wingert who has
actually voiced tony stark in a number
of marvel animated titles that's cool
almost exactly like robert downey jr
fury points to the palladium points of
tony's neck he says you become a problem
a problem i have to deal with contrary
to your belief you are not the center of
my universe now this line in the movie
flows directly into a reference to the
events in thor you have become a problem
a problem i have to deal with contrary
to your belief you are not the center of
my universe i have bigger problems than
you in the southwest region to deal with
but fury here never gets to that because
natasha's lithium dioxide injection
causes an adverse reaction that kills
tony now natasha in the movie said it's
not a cure just to base the symptoms
which she says here but draws out the
line as she realizes tony is dying it's
not a cure it just
abates the symptoms
you okay fury looks down at tony in
shock and he cross dissolves into the
watcher the slideshow takes us through
memorable shots from fury's big week in
the movies tony's hiding his poisoning
and fighting whiplash monaco bruce
banner emerging from some hulk wreckage
though notice they changed banner's
appearance to look more like mark
ruffalo who was recast as the character
after ed norton played him in the 2008
incredible hulk film just kind of
erasing ed noren's whole appearance from
the cinematic universe yeah i wish they
didn't do that i think it would have
been so much cooler to kind of
especially if you're doing a whole what
if alternate universe scenario if you're
not able to get some of the og actors to
voice some of these characters i don't
know might have been a neat way to make
some amends with good old edward norton
so he doesn't have to keep doing
celebrity roasts and having a dig at
marvel he would have wanted final cut
over the episode
yeah that's true and then some images
from the battle of new york a couple
years after that clint and natasha
fighting chitari hulk smashing loki and
the avengers lining up then we catch up
with agent bill coulson clark gregg
returning to voice in this episode he
finds mjolnir in the same framing from
that iron man 2 post-credits scene
meanwhile at the project pegasus base
the shield strike unit detains natasha i
may not have been a fan of tony stark
but i didn't kill him save your spin for
pierce i want you in new york first
thing for questioning frank grillo
returns to voice brock rumlow here
future crossbones he references pierce
aka world security council secretary
alexander pierce robert redford's
character from captain america winter
soldier and avengers end game and on the
right of that unit is rollins calallen
movie's character from redwood from
batman v
rodgers takes down this same unit in a
confined space in captain america winter
soldier natasha does the same as she
repeatedly jabs the guy in the jaw you
can see little dribbles of spit flying
out and there's just some really fun
animation direction on natasha's combat
staying on her use of her right leg
first to knee a guy then without
stepping down to kick a guy behind her
then keeping the leg up hooking over to
another guy and then bringing that heel
back on the guy behind her like neo
rumlow realizes she's escaped oh
come on
yeah the animation on the mouth swallow
character's talk in the show is a little
non-specific so in this case it looks
like rumblo is about to make the f
consonant like
on and then back at the mule near sight
in puente antiguo new mexico a
tournament in spanish translates to
ancient bridge an easter egg that was in
thor referencing this being a connection
point to the ancient bifrost bridge
hawkeye clint barton voiced by jeremy
renner says also no one can lift it not
even jackson need those crossfit yeah
agent jackson was actually one of the
shield agents at this site in the thor
film played by james no
when captain carter arrived through the
portal in that reality steve rogers
never went down into the ice with that
shield whereas that was his fate in this
universe as we learned in the final
scene
we're pointing that out too man he's a
caucasian male mid-20s with
really great hair
excuse me it's an accurate description
sir he's gorgeous and as thor struts
toward mjolnir he tosses his wet hair
similar to how chris hemsworth did
during these scenes in the movie the
animators also gave thor super blonde
eyebrows with no dark borderlines to
outline them as a way of evoking hems
the words weirdly
always stood out to you now in the film
it was colson who ordered hawkeye to
hold fury wasn't actually here because
coulson wanted to see if thor could lift
the hammer now it is fury but before
thor gets the chance clint slips and
lets the arrow fly and the bolt of
lightning ironically the force of nature
that should have empowered the god of
thunder that is a beautiful shot
nice beautiful shots corpse
wow
even while rotting he smells like
lavender really
i feel like that makes them a little bit
sadistic that's a little creepy yeah
it's a little it's a little necrophilic
yeah just gonna i'm just gonna say i
have respect for the dead i know marvel
likes their humor and they're like hey
this is animated show we gotta levity it
up but that is a little that's a little
perverted i've only smelled a few dead
people in my life and i didn't want to
but there's a point where you are
slutting around smelling people
isn't that right watson
yeah that's right buddy
yeah
i feed him dead people similar to how
the guardians of the galaxy sniffed and
drooled over his incapacitated body in
an infinite war
[Music]
this is a man
a handsome
muscular man on to culver university in
virginia the setting of the battle in
the 2008 hulk movie betty ross is voiced
by stephanie penicello and she's wearing
the same clothes that he wears in that
movie including her mother's necklace
that in the movie she pawns and banner
later returns to her betty helps natasha
realize that nanotech interfered with
the syringe a clue of course pointing to
pimtek and then on the table natasha
sees a hack in jacket versus stan lee's
pizza parlor
movie where banner works run by stanley
lieber his name a nod to stan lee and
he's played by actor paul soules who
voiced bruce banner in the 60s animated
series the marvel superheroes on fury's
screen during the call are files of all
the avengers candidates clint barton
thor tony stark on the left bruce banner
hulk and above him a female i thought
was natasha but that's actually the same
file photo of janet van dyne
early series mystery was right there in
front of him the whole time the death
star disappearance of his og avenger
that led to her daughter working for
shield and when she died her father hank
pym losing it bruce banner emerges from
the closet voiced by mark ruffalo
no need for violence agent romanov
that's probably not gonna work out
for anyone and the watcher watches
coulson drive out to the new mexico site
where an asgardian army led by loki
arrives they look like they're from
earth maybe middle earth
coulson naturally is into lord of the
rings loki voiced by tom hiddleston of
course orders you would do best to kneel
before a god just like he ordered the
germans to nail
and when he tried to force the
mongolians to kneel to him in loki
episode one he introduces himself i am
loki crown prince of asgard the rightful
king of yertin
yotenheim
and god of
mischief yeah crowned king of asgard but
rightful king of yotenheim this would
mean that had thor died in the first
thor film loki would have been
unchallenged in seizing the throne
though at this point in the narrative he
has not yet taken jotunheim odin's
probably still in his odin's sleep which
lady siff voiced by jaime alexander
seems to indicate he's not wrong the old
father would want us to listen honestly
what i got from that moment and this is
just my own little cynical mind is that
that's the second time with like
bringing back loki he gives that speech
and then they make a joke out of it of
him being interrupted
in some way to ruin his glorious purpose
speech that joke felt kind of flat to me
a little bit you could really really see
it coming this is the go-to joke for
that moment but eric voss did answer
some questions that we were actually
having during our discussion wait a
minute how how would he just become the
person in charge of asgard all of a
sudden wouldn't have something to do
with this we were trying to recall if it
was the dark world or if thor won if
that was the one where odin fell into
asleep
but uh yeah that makes sense that makes
sense thanks for clearing that up mr vos
also among loki's ranks are the warriors
three vulstag fandral and hogan and the
far background the asgardian destroyer
armor they get to not be characters
again he uses the casket of ancient
winters to freeze fury's forces he
actually found this in odin's vault in
the thor film in the scene where odin
confirmed to him his frost giant lineage
and loki later used this against
heimdall during his coup of asgard bruce
and natasha appear on the campus
crosswalk bridge where banner is
cornered in the movie general thaddeus
ross appears voiced by mike mcgill and
banner turns into the hulk and natasha
dives out sticking her famous landing
pose that elena below made fun of her
for in black widow now i like how this
version of the whole uses design
elements from both the 2008 ed norton
film like the longer shaggier hair but
also the 2012 ruffalo redesign like the
humanistic expressions in the face also
chest hair and i honestly think they
kept those sympathetic ruffle features
to make this even more shocking
ah
god now it is largely so disturbing
because of hulk's confused facial
expressions as he suffocates his own
inflating flesh and i hate to do this
but if you show up folks inflation frame
by frame his neck and cheeks cram into
his traps in his chest and the explosion
points burst out from the creases
between his muscles as they squeeze
together now the explosion is green
smoke i assume because disney might have
been uneasy
or wet tissue or bone or guts but you
could also see this as a kind of blood
mist as hank pym's tech vaporizes him
from the inside out yeah this frame by
frame stuff ain't as fun when imagery
ain't so disney
[Laughter]
wow that was the most disturbing moment
out of the whole episode it's even even
more i thought it was just disturbing
contextual wise because yeah it was some
of the disturbing nature of it felt a
little bit undone by the fact of oh it's
just smoke it's not going to be guts
because your mind's kind of prepping you
for guts because normally when you see
an explosion of anyone with a human
anatomy form you're expecting guts but
it wasn't that so i was like okay it was
still disturbing but not as disturbing
as it could have been but then when they
slow it down you're like oh that is
actually really gross and you can pay
close attention to the details right
there oh yeah just everything bursting
out through the seams and like his head
being crushed under the weight of his
own traps the good thing is the more you
think about it the grosser it becomes
yeah that's true even if it's solid
yeah man you would have freaking
scott lang is not living up to his
potential he could have taken on thanos
now natasha calls colson to get his
password to log into the shield server
hashtag
steve steve steve i heart steve 0704 wow
good one colson yes reminder of
coulson's fan crush on steve rogers with
0704 being steve's birthday of july 4.
natasha brings up files on phil coulson
nick fury janet van dyne maria hill and
alexander pierce but janet is listed as
deceased yes and then over in the left
corner you can see everything a lot of
comments
members at 11 23 the day before and then
the camera cuts back to natasha as she
realizes who accessed this quote a woman
who died two years ago referring to
janet's daughter of hope
and fury listens to this voicemail in
isabella's diner the town eatery in the
2011 thor film colson quotes the
avengers initiative speech 2 fury you
know that diner scene reminded me oh i
can't remember which marvel one shot it
is from the guy who you learn is bad and
captain can forgetting his name right
now he's a captain america winner
soldier sitwell yes jasper jasper sit
well guy with the glasses yeah yeah teen
agents of shield uh he pops up here and
there but many seasons ago since how you
know i don't know if you guys seen that
marvel one shot that's immediately where
my mind ran to i just didn't call it out
in the moment because uh i would look
like a damn fool for not knowing what it
was called it shows in the memo that was
written by fury perhaps part of the
paperwork that fury originally drafted
in that final scene of captain marvel
and that could be why fury now retrieves
the captain marvel pager that was
boosted with creed tech that he and
danvers agreed that they would use to
summon her at the end of the captain
marvel film and of course he later used
in the infinity war post-credits scene
the watcher also oversees this misty
cemetery in san francisco now in
avengers end game a memorial was set up
overlooking the golden gate bridge on
chrissy field on the city side of the
bay but in this shot the city is in the
background meaning this cemetery would
be on the other side of the bridge in
marin county fury or whom he thinks oh
wow
if it isn't hank pam yeah we hear a
little insect buzz there for hank pym in
his yellow jacket armor which natasha
might have been able to hear ever so
softly in the library earlier
michael douglas returns to boy's pym the
balls you have to come here
and stand that's
coarse language she's wearing the yellow
jacket suit in the comics family friends
suit up as yellowjacket after he left
the ant-man mantle not really a good guy
in the 80s comics now of course fury is
very much out of character i doubt she'd
mind considering she's dead her mother
was an agent i don't give a damn about
any of them yes this irreverence comes
from him actually being loki disguises
fury which is why the only time his tone
shifts to sirius is when he asks about
thor and what a thor prince of asgard
now fury responds agent
that's a good attack okay
outside odessa ukraine odessa now as i
went into an inside marvel odessa could
refer to that shield mission that
natasha romanov went on where she ran
into the winter soldier five years ago i
was escorting a nuclear engineer out of
iran somebody shot out my tires near
odessa but the winter soldier was there
so he shot him
straight through me
but in this reality pope van dyne could
have been fury's go-to avenger to go on
such missions before he would take his
big swings on natasha romanov but
whereas natasha survived the winter
soldier's bullet hope did not wow so
the winner soldier couldn't kill natasha
romanoff but he was able to maybe shoot
the freaking wasp instead
because he just hit her likes point
blank with the bullet when she was tiny
it's blue room he's just that good of an
assassin
blew right through her blood missed all
over we don't know if she was in you
know miniature form then but still
that's uh she was three-quarter scale if
the theory lines up that's impressive
hank reveals it was he and natasha's
syringe he who loosened clint's fingers
to release the arrow in a moment evoking
when scott lang clung to hawkeye's arrow
in civil war it was hank pym who buzzed
into clint's ear and mushed up his brain
and it was hank pym who threw a resizing
disc like the ones we've seen ant-man
use on hulk's heart which caused it to
enlarge separate from the rest of his
body and i guess about blood at a faster
rate than his other glands and muscles
could adjust for what a way to go i
guess since hulk grows at a rate
proportional to gross anger something
that would be linked to his heart rate i
guess this could happen it's just
upsetting that hank pym would know to do
this because hulk is supposed to be
invulnerable even two internal
projectiles like banner in avengers says
that he put a gun in his mouth and hulk
spit out the bullet but i guess that
doesn't apply to magical pym tech
applied to internal organs i love how
just upset eric sounds about that whole
thing you really considered the
realities of this you seem so disturbed
and like mad at those who did not
properly protect the whole kieran so
anyways traumatic really traumatic
he said so disturbed by this
it is funny the more we talk about it
this is like the most family-friendly
iteration of marvel lately and yet that
is incredibly disturbing the more you
learn and think about it using hulk's
own growth powers against him between
this and pimp articles having time
travel capabilities anyone with pymtek
is potentially the deadliest killer in
the mcu rightly the studs answer the
age-old question of what would happen if
ant-man flew up inside there you go
and decided to see
[Music]
fury definitely swats away hank he
blocks his blows he evades his lasers
and he uses duplication projection of
course revealing himself as the god of
mischief you know what i'm not a fan of
with the fight scenes of some of them
are handled with the motion when they're
moving it there's something that's kind
of stiff about it's like
yeah
you know yeah it doesn't seem to be much
like rotation with the shoulders or the
hips really this is kind of like this
stiff way of fight and you see it with
natasha when she's fighting yeah i mean
maybe there's something justified here
with loki's immense ability as a warrior
when he's fighting at the same time it's
like
come on yeah why do they want cells to
rotate that body whereas if you just
have a stationary torso and make the
arms move you save a lot of animation
and i like how the reveal uses this mix
of samuel l jackson's laughter with tom
hiddleston's laughter because nick fury
would not be laughing maniacally in this
moment loki would
[Laughter]
it's just kind of fun like seeing chris
evans do an impression of loki do an
impression of him loki and a not at all
surprising twist takes over the planet
marches into the u.n and makes his big
speech to the world it's the unspoken
truth of humanity that you crave
subjugation the bright viewer of freedom
hoggles you diminishes your life's joy
of course this is loki's speech to the
germans from avengers it's the unspoken
truth of humanity
that you crave subjugation
the bright lure of freedom diminishes
your life's joy actually in times square
the chiron over there on the left reads
green explosion at culver yeah that's
what you want to call it there's also a
coffee tree cafe billboards for
bulgarian olympia the musical but then
on the far right an ad for pinko doce
that was the juice from the 2008 hulk
that was so cool
you know what i really love about loki
winning this time around because this
whole week is building up to when you
know uh they have to fight loki in the
chitauri
as the avengers assemble loki ends up
winning without having to do some type
of alien invasion
at all
he's just plays it smart yeah that's his
best week ever he's the king of asgard
now that thor is dead and then he can
just move right into earth yeah he
manipulates his way there without really
having to over exert himself at all and
it's kind of brilliant
about like oh damn he really came out on
top on this one fury and coulson look
over the row of coffins containing the
avengers remains i don't know what you
put in there for hulk but each are
draped with their logo iron man's helmet
thor's hammer hawkeye's shield and zero
hulk's fist and black widow's hourglass
but there's only five because there's
one avenger left still frozen in ice i'm
curious though by this moment because
most of them are not decorated heroes by
this point in the story iron man makes
sense to me thor
they didn't even real they didn't even
know who he was yeah you know until like
a couple days ago but he just showed up
in new mexico and got killed the hulk
was an enemy of the state you know
yeah i mean black widow makes sense
because she worked for shield yada yada
yada yada
but i guess yeah i guess it's really
just two of them or i'm like why would
they be as decorated with their funeral
or their burial you know and like look
we gotta build we gotta we gotta you
know have have an artist design their
symbol on the coffin yeah and fury wipes
away that for us from cap's shield
welcome back captain
so where's the fight yes captain
marvel's glow reflects on fury's face
similar to the way it did on tony
stark's face when she rescued him in
in-game carol here is voiced by
alexandra daniels and she's wearing the
red on blue beautiful
as opposed to the one with the gold trim
that she wore when she met with the
avengers at the start of end game or the
blue topped one on the other side of the
flip and end game so whenever her first
costume change occurred it would have
happened closer to the modern era i
would be curious to see a new avengers
lineup co-captained by steve rogers and
carol danvers cool what light this could
shed on carol's mystery backstory with
monica rambo something alluded to a few
times in one division and expected to be
explored in the marvels support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options including our marvel what if
limited edition shirt i'd love this over
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
all right
another job well done i gotta say you
know like we had some of our criticisms
about this particular episode and
sometimes it sounds like a thing that
we're just saying but this time around
especially i i gotta really say like
it's happened with black widow and this
happened with this this episode in
particular as well this video has
successfully made me appreciate the
episode that much more uh not gonna lie
like i i do have a much fonder
appreciation for it now so yeah yeah
much more disturbed by bruce yeah
uh well guys subscribe to your rockstars
if you haven't done so already once
again thank you to eric voss for helping
us out with that little spiderman no way
home opening and uh hey we'll catch you
guys soon thank you so much for being
here check out more we got to offer by
subscribing and clicking that bell and
hitting that like button smash thumbs up
[Music]